let us begin and let's go in order of
ascending rating
let's begin with the game against mr
olama i gotta give the man a rematch
he's been stalwartly following my stream
let's give him a game with white
and we will get to everybody
[Music]
now let us play a sicilian
oh my gosh momo with another five gifted
holy smokes man
now um those of you who have been yeah
we are we'll
i'll play you two demon you're the
freaking man uh those of you have been
following my five minute speed run know
that which sicilian is what i
essentially
played almost exclusively i will not
play the sicilian i will play the night
or
this time now i recommend for people in
like the 14 1500 range the accelerated
dragon with knight c6
here assuming that alex plays d4 which
is the open sicilian i'm going to play
the night or
i actually played the night or yeah he
does i played the night off as my main
opening from the time i was about
1600 to the time i was 2500.
knight f6 and who can tell me what move
signals the night or if this is not yet
the night off
because here there are uh four actually
one could say four main three main
sicilian lines
and then two sidelines a6 is the night
or i will explain
everything after the game just because
it will take me a while
um just because it will take me a while
to fully flesh out all of the details
um but i will say uh in kant to put
things in context
one sec keyboard is that to put things
in context
g6 is the dragon knight c6
is the rouser or the classical sicilian
e6 is the cheveningen
and e5 not a great move is called the
cut now or thank you camelizer so we
play the night earth
we play the knight orb now essentially
the simple way to think about a6 is that
it covers the b5 square
so no bishop b5 check and not only does
it cover the b5 square it also
potentially prepares the move b7 and b5
grabbing space on the queen side
that is actually one of the main ideas
across most sitalians
f3 is called the english attack and here
is where i'm going to play a move
that may confuse a lot of people so
prepare to be confused for the
essentially the entirety of this game
but i will explain everything
does anybody know what the main move is
here for black in fact black has two
main moves
100 and one bit so we can play the move
e6 that leads to the chevening against
structure
but the move that i grew up playing is
e5 attacking the knight
why is this move confusing on the
surface what is this
what is the drawback the obvious
drawback of this move
what is the sort of what what jumps out
at you immediately
when it weakens not only the d6 pawn but
also look at the hole that it creates on
d5
and those two things as we know
frequently go hand in hand
the pawn and then the square in front of
of the pawn um
both become very weak
um but uh
the hard thing to understand about
utility is what exactly it is that you
get in return
for this week pawn and this week's
square and
it's hard for me to explain this in
words that's why the sicilian is such a
concrete and theoretical opening because
there are so many tactical ideas there's
so many subtleties and
the combination of these ideas and
subtleties constitute blacks
one could say compensation for the weak
pawn and the weak square
now first of all we need to deal with
the development of this bishop
and we develop it to e6 in order to at
least
lend some cover to the d5 square so that
he cannot establish a blockade on d5
if he plays knight t5 we can take on d5
and he would have to replace that with a
pawn
which is not very desirable so bishop g5
is actually not the main move bishop b3
is the main move this creates a pin
how should we unpin ourselves what is
like the simplest move here no need to
reinvent the wheel
we simply need to develop our other two
pieces now h6 would be possible
but actually i would argue that h6 is
inaccurate why
because if we play h6 right he drops his
bishop back to h4 and there's a problem
the problem is that when we castle this
pawn on h6
is going to act as a hook which white
can exploit by putting
the pawn eventually on g5 so we don't
actually want to
uh shuffle our king's side pawns we want
to leave that pawn structure intact
because we are going to castle short so
bishop comes to e7
and as often happens when we weaken the
d5 square this knight on b8 actually
wants to go out to d7 in fact
that's what we are going to do the
reason why is that the knights now are
in this configuration which
you guys should be familiar with they
defend each other and now we officially
have both castled on opposite sides
let the nador fun begin now it is
actually easy now to see why bishop g5
is inaccurate
what is white's main attacking weapon a
main attacking plan in the english
attack like how does white usually
attack
here and again no need to reinvent the
wheel it's pretty straightforward yeah
pawn storm so h4 is one move
but the other is g4 g5 and what's the
problem here thank you uncle robs the
problem is that the bishop on g5 is
simply
in the way of the pawn if the bishop
were on e3 white could do this in one
fell swoop here
he might have to move the bishop away
from g5 and
every tempo is crucial absolutely
crucial in positions like these
now alex has very sensibly started with
the move h4
we have to start attacking on the queen
side and here is where the move a6
comes in handy what should black now do
yes
rav b5 is absolutely right we play b5
and um we play b5
and we both are attacking on either side
of the board now black wants to play b4
a5 a4 the actual way of attacking in the
night or thank you andy starr
appreciate the tier one the actual way
of attacking in the night or is not
particularly hard to understand we are
using our pawns
to essentially get rid of pieces that
surround
each side's king white uses his pawns
to break apart my own structure and make
holes
but as we are going to see alex is going
to pay a very steep price for this
bishop being on g5 here you can see how
much it blocks
the pawn from coming to g5 and this
tempo is going to be absolutely
crucial we go b4
i hope this is making sense by the way
because i've never played this opening
there's so much to talk about i'm not
necessarily being
overly coherent but i hope that i'm at
least
making remote sense here in terms of why
i'm doing what i'm doing
okay so knight d5 now we don't want to
let this knight marinate on d5
uh because it's it's an annoying piece
so we want to take it with what should
we take that
night should we take it with our knight
or should we take it with our bishop
again the reasoning is very simple we
take it
no we don't take knight takes now we
take with the bishop because if we take
with the knight
then he takes back and look at this
bishop on e6 very carefully
that bishop is going to be trapped and
then the bishop on g5
is not lost because it's defended by the
h-bond so we take with the bishop
and then after he takes back that pawn
on d5 is almost like a dental
filling it plays into our hands because
it closes up the center
it closes up the weakness and by closing
up the weakness it also closes up
the other weakness the pawn on d6 it's
still weak from a
sort of general standpoint but it's now
inaccessible because the d file was the
main
avenue through which white exerted
pressure on that pawn
now we continue our attack with a5
followed by a4
this is why i play the night or guys as
you can as you know it fits my style
like a glove uh because it offers very
sharp positions in virtually every game
virtually every line
a4 now king b1 is a good move alex moves
his king aside tries to bring it to a
safer square
the problem is we are a little bit
further advanced in our attack
than alex is in his although i have to
say the position remains very
complicated
now we are not going to succeed simply
by moving our pawns we also need to
bring in the beef
we need to bring in the cavalry we need
to bring in the beef
and we do that first and foremost by
moving away the queen
uh where should we put that queen so
this pawn is actually hanging i don't
necessarily want to give that one up
yeah let's go queen b6 this also
connects the rooks
and allows this rook to come over to c8
um
you guys might say well isn't it a good
idea to sack this pawn
uh because you know it opens up the b
file but that's not
quite as simple as it may appear i don't
see a need
to engage in this when queen b6 is a
perfectly good move
now we can actually go b3
and i'll explain the details the finer
details behind this move after the game
but it should make sense what we're
doing right now we're opening up the
position we are sacrificing upon
in order to open up files surrounding
white's king we are now going to use
these files
and mount a frontal assault against
white's king
in fact there is already a very tempting
sacrifice that
must be considered further sacrifice
queen a6 would monitor the queen
but what should we do and i actually
need to charge my
keyboard so just give me a second as you
think about the move
so the move is actually sacrificing on
a2
and let's do it let us sacrifice on a2
what are we doing we are cutting the
legs off from the knight
so what we are and we are also opening
up the afl so if our king takes a2 we
are going to go rook a8 check we're
going to chase away the king
then we're going to recapture the knight
with our queen which
leads to a situation look at how weak
the king is the a file is completely
wide open we are threatening a very
nasty check we are only an exchange down
and this is the point that i really want
to clarify to
everybody no matter what your rating is
sacrifices
exist on a sliding scale not all
sacrifices are the same
sacrificing a queen is not should not be
mentioned in the same breath of
sacrificing an exchange
why because here even if our
attack backfires even if we don't quote
unquote succeed
the game is not going to be over okay i
have a piece for a rook that is not the
end of the world
even if we screw up and the attack fails
so you shouldn't be
too scared alex says balls yeah this is
a ballsy decision for sure
but i'm without even calculating i can
basically tell
that this attack has enough firepower to
succeed
because look at how many pieces are in
the attack we have a roku queen
this knight on d7 may seem to be outside
the zone of the attack
but how can it quickly and efficiently
re-enter
the attack what can we do to re-enter
the attack with a knight
we can go not re-enter just enter i mean
the knight never really entered the
attack in the first place i don't know
what i'm talking about
um so knight c5 is the move yes
knight c5 is um
the move and then from c5 the knight can
further go
um he says do i have a move uh alex the
problem is i can't type in the chat
on this account i have my chat sort of
disabled
uh but i think white is actually in
trouble here the more i look at this
position the more i see
that white does not have the ability to
bring enough defenders
i think computer the computer will
probably find some way
to defend against this attack but the
night off is a very human opening
it puts very human problems in front of
your opponent and it's actually
withstood
the test of computers as well which is a
fun fact
um look at that sub count f3 is hanging
as well great point we can
worst come stores take on f3 and
cause this entire pawn train to collapse
and alex speaking of collapse queen c3
makes sense you're trying to get rid of
the queen
but you are taking the defender
off of the rook on d1 queen takes d1
check that wins the rook back now we are
up a piece
this pawn on d5 is also going to fall
the game is over
let's have some fun with history i'm
going to tell you guys a little bit
about the night or
so bishop c1 let's not um
take our own feed off the gas pedal what
should we take on d5
with should we take with the knight or
should we take with
the queen
what do you guys say definitely yeah
definitely in the night the queen is
perfectly placed on d1 it's picture
perfect
why move it why move it from its amazing
square where it's sort of pinning the
bishop
and controlling f3 and pinning the other
way too now we have a choice we can
treat queens
sure it's uh that leads to a relatively
straightforwardly winning position
we have to be careful there are traps
here if we take on f3 mindlessly
then we allow bishop g2 which skewers
the queen to the knight so careful
instead let's dip the queen back to b3
queen a4 is the same idea but why
sacrifice back the
again and again and again when you have
an idea spend five seconds asking
yourself if you don't have a simpler
way to execute that idea without giving
up
the essence of that idea which is not to
say that queen a4
is necessarily bad probably black is
winning there but you want to
minimize the the margin of error
that doesn't mean you don't want to take
risks that's not what i'm saying
but what i'm saying is that when you
have the same way to do something
without sacrificing that often makes
sense
okay queen d3 again we can trade queens
but there is a far
more straightforward and efficient win
what can we do
fork town is right we have a night in
the vicinity of an open king
and so we deliver the fork good game
alex actually you played very well
up until uh that point when i played
rook takes a2 let's pack let's uh delve
into this game
let me pull up chess space and let you
guys know a little bit about the history
of the night or so
who is the night or named after the
night or is named after miguel neidorf
uh originally moy schneider polish
grand master moved to argentina to
escape
uh prosecution during world war ii had a
very long and successful career as a
grandmaster
and of course uh stands behind the night
but as often happens we ask ourselves
the question was neither of the first
person to play the night or
drama role please was miguel night or
the first person to play the night off
and when was the night our first played
the answer is
actually no nairob was not even close
to the first person to play the night of
night or first played it in 1939
and the night off was first played in
1899
by pertz halawa in a correspondence game
a russian
obscure russian correspondence player
was the first to play the night off in
1899
it was not played over the board until
1926
when french grand master savioli
itartakauer or also originally russian
tartakover
later immigrated to france uh kind of a
very colorful chess figure grandmaster
writer he actually was the first person
to play the night
over the board it was not until 1939
13 years later after approximately 15
times
of the night of being played didn't
miguel night or actually play it
in a game against a danish
player in the olympiad in 1939. the cool
little stuff here right uh
again just because it's called the night
or doesn't mean knight or was the first
person to
play it now essentially
um in this position right
in this position well they named it
after him i think largely because night
or
um and what you have to understand here
is that
it's not that there is a committee of p
some people may think there's a round
table committee of like
chess sages with long beards i mean
let's name this opening
oh well we have five shots of sky and
night or fat whatever that's the first
name i see
okay okay that sounds good
um that's not how it happens i think the
naming of opening is a fascinating
process
it sort of happens by consensus through
the years
um it's not that there is a specific
committee that made so one possibility
is that neither
was the first person to play the night
or in the way that we play it now
the people who played it before him were
sort of experimenting
they weren't familiar with some of these
main ideas such as e5 whereas night or
himself
displayed a far greater understanding he
actually analyzed this
and analyzed it very deeply so that's
one possibility sorry to
drone on for so long i i hope this is
not too too boring we're talking about
the etymology of openings i think it's
actually kind of interesting
um but it's one of the most reputable
openings in existence it is played at
all levels
it is played very very frequently at the
highest levels and has been for over 50
years
uh and that is a very surefire sign of a
good opening
uh now g6 is the dragon as you guys know
that is the dragon e6 is called the
cheveningen
knight c6 is the classical situain or
the rouser
and then there are a variety of very
rare
alternatives there's bishop to d7 which
is actually not a very not a bad move
and there's e5 which is not considered
to be very good it's premature
and by the way e5 uh is premature
precisely because white delivers a check
on b5 a very nasty check
so that's the bottom line rationale of
the move a6 you are taking away this
important square from white's pieces
both his knights
and his bishop and you are preparing an
eventual queen side expansion with the
move b5
so it's a pretty load-bearing move you
are also very flexible right you don't
commit to a system of development that
in and of itself
is worth its weight in gold the other
systems here
have the drawback of committing a
particular piece to a particular square
g6 already informs white that you're
going to fianchetto thank you l3o
e6 is also inflexible because playing e5
after that would be a waste of a tempo
knight c6 is also inflexible because
guess what in the night or if the knight
frequently comes out to d7 as it did in
the game
and then the rare moves are just kind of
awkward
so um i hope that kind of makes
generals i don't want to speak too
generally about the night or because it
is such a specific opening and such a
theoretical opening
by the way the first person to have this
position
in the year 1890 bird
henry edward byrd one of the strongest
british players of the 19th century
uh played the dragon actually for the
first time in 1890
and uh then the chevening game became
popular so the night off wasn't really
popular until the 50s okay anyways
enough history let's get to the the meat
let's get to the meat
now here's the thing that makes the
night or so
incredibly complicated it is the simple
abundance of
possibilities for white on the sixth
move white has approximately
ten viable continuation here and all of
them
must be studied very very carefully if
you are to play the night or on
any kind of high level what are these
possibilities well
first of all bishop g5 is the sort of
traditional main line
then you can develop the bishop to e3
i have a funny story for you guys
and to understand this story can you
guys first tell me is this
a legitimate move is this a legitimate
development square for the bishop
what can you guys tell me yes or no
repair it to like not be it's no you
walk first of all
you're kind of biting on granite so like
positionally that's not very good but
also
as obviously e5 but here's the funny
thing a couple of years ago i taught at
a chess camp
and i teach at this chess camp every
year it's in atlanta
and i have kind of a homeroom group so
my homeroom group was the highest rated
group 2000 to 2200 rated kids these are
very talented kids
and um basically
i was doing a lecture on on openings and
on opening theory
and i was able to convince this room
full of kids who all of whom were above
2000
that in the last couple of months bishop
f4
became this new sensation in the night
of
where white basically i invented some
weird line where white just like gives
up a piece
and everybody believes me um everybody
believed me of course this is just
absolute crap you just lose a piece
but i could not keep a straight face for
very long anyways
that's just what i like to do so there's
bishop g5 there's bishop e3
there is f3 as my opponent played in the
game which covers the g4 square and
actually prepares bishop e3
then you can develop this bishop you can
develop it to either
of the three possible squares that's
already one two
three let's delete this move one two
three four
five six then you can play a4 to stop
b57
you can fiat keto the bishop eight nine
and h4
has become popular recently ten queen f3
11 queen e212 and that's not even it
there's rook g1 and f4 i mean
literally all of these moves are
dangerous this is the task
that awaits the player who wants to play
the night off well now obviously you
don't literally need to
study all of these lines to the same
degree of depth
there are a couple of lines which are
more popular than others bishop g5
by popularity by pure number of games
played
remains the most popular move 75 000
games according to megabase
close second is bishop e3 72 000 and
bishop e2
with 51. bishop b2 is considered the
quiet line white is going for short
castle
yeah so that's the issue right that's
why i'm not going to spend too long
talking about all of these lines in the
game alex plays f3 this is called the
english attack
uh named after several english players
who sort of pioneered
this system of attacking in many types
of sicilian positions
what do i mean by this well the idea of
f3 is twofold first of all as i
mentioned earlier you are covering
the g4 square this should make sense to
everybody right because
the drawback of the move bishop e3 is
that knight g4 is actually a very
legitimate
idea so you play f3 first in order to
stop this
but there is a secondary idea which alex
showed during the game and that is to
prepare the move g4 when black castle
short
and black is going to castle short
because castling along for black in
these positions is just unthinkable
the queen side is too weak
i would say cody five cents like around
a thousand you should already start
developing an opening repertoire but it
really depends on the specific arc of
your development
no f3 is very common f3 is
um f3 is one of the most reputable moves
you have in this position
so e5 was my choice and i think that as
the game went along you guys were able
to
kind of understand a little bit better
why it is
justified to give up the square and to
make the spawn weak
uh so any questions so far about what
i've explained about the night or
i wanted to lay the groundwork a little
bit uh now we can delve into the actual
game so the main line here
as people generate their questions is
bishop to e3
and could somebody remind me why
this square is better ultimately than
the g5 score what is the
reason for that as we saw in the game
yes so you want to unroll the red carpet
for that g pawn and there is a
zebra standing on that red carpet in the
event of bishop g5 it is far more
important to have that red carpet
unfettered than to create this temporary
pin against the knight which is easily
solved
by bishop to e7 right so bishop e3 and
now
bishop b7 queen d2 castles castles and
you get kind of the same situation
that you do in uh that you did in the
game literally
with the difference that the bishop is
on e3 rather than g5 which means the
white now has the move g5 and as i
explained this one difference in tempo
creates a world of propagates through to
the attack makes white's attack far more
effective
and uh this only begins the theory of
the night or if black plays b4
counter-attacking white's knight
and things get absolutely crazy here
there is so much theory
uh but you are welcome to look at this
on your own this is outside the scope of
the speed run
yeah so white doesn't develop the light
squared bishop for now and
one of the reasons the night orf is
challenging is because to play the night
or
for either side you must you absolutely
must
violate certain opening principles you
are not playing at quote-unquote by the
book
and one of those examples is keeping the
bishop on f1 you don't literally need to
develop it
uh just because you are prioritizing
quickly castling queenside and starting
the attack the bishop is actually not
essential
for the time being uh for the attack but
i can show you several games and this is
what makes this line
really cool this is what makes this line
really cool
this bishop on f1 it might seem like a
lame sort of like a lame piece here
uh it's doing absolutely nothing but
guess what
if black's bishop ever disappears from
e6 and it often does
if this bishop lands on c4 it exerts
insane pressure on black's king i have
had myself a disaster game
in which i allowed this bishop to get
active and let me tell you
when that bishop gets active it gets
angry
let me show you guys one of the most
painful games of my chess career
um a quick detour again i know i'm
spending a long time on this but
hopefully people are into it thank you
nils the chef for the
500 bits we are celebrating 8 000 subs
unbelievable stuff thank you again
everybody and thank you for sticking
around
let me find this game
okay this will help you understand
some of the complexities involved in
navigating the night of waters
and the tournament started off already
on a bad on a bad note
i was upset in rounds one and two i made
two draws against two thousands
and uh then i won round three and then
round four i play a swiss
swiss player rated 2093 and i get
absolutely
crushed which uh crushed
also my spirits and my morale and this
started a
probably six month to nine month slump
one of the biggest lumps of my chest
career where
i dipped all the way to about 23 30. 50
points is a lot at this level
i had several bad tournaments but in the
end i emerged much stronger i learned a
lot of lessons
how did this happen well we have a
knight or literally the same exact line
by transposition
notice that he puts the bishop on e3 and
literally what i just showed happens now
i'm going to fast forward through the
crazy line
this is all theory and then my opponent
plays the move f takes
e6 the main move in this position um
is is actually knight b to d4 which
looks crazy but there is a justification
behind this i was not familiar with f
takes e6 but
what my opponent does is then play the
move king b1
okay you might look at this move take a
second to just like adjust your eyes to
this
you might look at this and say what is
this that's what i said i was cocky i
was confident
i said king b1 girl like king b1
you're going to let me take on a2 with
the rook and then i'm going to put a
queen on a5 and i'm going to trackmate
him on a1
in fact i am already threatening to play
rook a1
king takes a1 and this is a very classic
yes i'm black here
this is a very classic checkmating idea
it turns out that rook takes a2 loses
the game this is a
losing blunder does anybody see
the vicious resource that white has in
this position
remember how i introduced this game this
bishop on f1 it looks horrible
but there is this beautiful c4 square
that is awaiting this bishop the only
thing that white must solve
is this annoying pawn on b3 this pawn
needs to be dealt with
don't forget to check retreating moves
knight c3 you can just take that knight
knight c1 double exclam amazing move
several ideas first of all this does not
work anymore
because that pesky knight on c1 is an
essential knight on c10 guards a2
second of all the rook is attacked third
of all bishop c4
is prepared and that is a vicious pin
fourth of all
knight takes b3 as possible i played
queen a8 out of desperation
threatening mate on a1 and he plays
knight takes b3 the game is over
this rock on a2 is now stranded
and loose and nothing can be done along
the a file look at how the knight
is just doing it all and bishop c4
cannot be stopped like
literally there aren't enough resources
in black's position
to stop bishop c4 in basketball
phil jackson famous coach he would
always write that a
missed corner three when a three-point
shot
is shot from the corner of the
basketball court
and it is missed he famously wrote that
it results frequently in a layup or
dunk that is a very easy shot on the
other end that is because
uh the configuration the way i interpret
it
required to produce an open
three-pointer from the corner is such
that
the players are not ready to defend okay
and the same thing can happen here right
this is the problem of the failed attack
i have configured all of my pieces for
the express purpose of checkmating him
and all of a sudden i have to switch
completely from checkmate mode
to defend mode and look at look at the
state the sorry state of my pieces
they're all clustered together
none of them can stop bishop c4 so i
went rook f3 out of desperation
look at this absolute monster then he
goes rook f1 and he checkmates me down
the f file
yeah just he just took all of my pieces
and he won
queen a4 and now boom at the end rook
takes f6 and guess what peace literally
wins him the game it is that bishop
g takes f6 queen g8 is checkmate
okay um well the best move i actually
don't even remember
i believe that the best move is to take
on c2
yes b takes c2 queen takes c2 and now
you vary and now you want to take this
pawn on g5 so you want to grab the pawn
white has compensation for the pawn but
later you want to bring your knight out
to b6
in order to control the c4 square not to
let the bishop develop itself
that's a handful guys but hopefully um
but hopefully this makes at least
some degree of sense but back to the
speedrun why did i show this position
there is a specific lesson here and a
general piece of advice here even if you
don't play the night or
the specific lesson is that this bishop
on f1 even though it can be
dormant for a long period of time you
should not
uh it can end up being on c4 and can end
up being very strong
a general piece of advice is that when
you have a piece
that is on its initial square um
this draws back to the concept of
kinetic and potential energy a piece may
not be doing anything on one particular
move or in one particular position
but you should not sort of abandon that
piece entirely you should
think about where that piece can
ultimately end up and how strong it can
be sometimes the pieces that seem to do
absolutely nothing
end up being the pieces that win you the
game when they open up
that essentially is the concept of
potential energy
which i feel very strongly about enough
talking
let's get back to the game so we have
this development h4 b5 we start
attacking
alex runs into this problem where the
bishop blocks
the move g5 and white must waste some
time
knight d5 bishop takes d5 again we don't
want to do this
because this traps the bishop on e6 the
bishop has nowhere to go
if the diagonal is exactly that's
another point right a bish a piece
particularly bishop or rook can be on
its initial square
and it can be perfectly well developed
the rook is developed
developed does not mean moved out of its
initial square developed means it
literally is doing something okay
um so bishop takes d5 then a5 a4
get the queen in very straightforward b3
sacking the pawn to open up files this
was the critical moment
rook takes a2 sacking the exchange
temporarily sacking the rook you guys
might look at this and say
okay i get it right but how do you know
how did i know to check for this well
guess what
that's why it's so hard to get into the
night or if you have to gain a lot of
experience in the night or
in order to basically know about these
ideas this is actually pattern
recognition
i had done something very very very
similar
uh many many years ago where i basically
uh played this b4 b3 idea and
could have also sacrificed my rook on
a2 now watch this 2008
and i'm telling you i played the night
oh for many years i wasn't always good
at it
i had disaster games all the way up
until the end
so last lugo 2008 i played this
tournament i played
played at i am and uh in this position
guess how i continued the attack
guess how i continued the attack
pawns on b4 and a4 we need to open up
white's king
b3 exactly takes takes
and knight takes b3 and in this position
my coach tore into me
for i missed a brilliant tactical
resource
what resource did i miss and after the
game i analyzed this very
closely and i would never forget about
this resource again
bingo rook takes a2 same exact concept
now this time
the bishop is doing the honors and the
queen is actually separating the king
from the knight queen a check this is
not possible because if queen takes a5
and the knight is pinned
the king must move bishop takes b3 and
you guys should see that black has a
very
very strong attack when a2 is a
checkmate threat the game is not over
white goes knight c1 but basically
you've got the rook to the b-file the
bishop does come out to c4
but black is a very strong attacker
due to control over the b file and ideas
of queen a3 i ended up drawing the game
i played a nice game
even without this line but i never
forgot this idea again that is how
learning works
that is why it's important to analyze
your games because you see these ideas
and you might get discouraged in the
short time it's never going to happen
again
but who knows many maybe many years
later you get another chance to apply a
similar idea
um so here rook takes a2 king takes a2
okay and intuitively i determined
that i have enough for the exchange and
the computer confirms it black is
completely winning here
so i think alex's decisive mistake
actually happened in this position
what should white do to keep things
relatively closed
down on the queen side this does not
solve all of white's problems
but the move a3 is a very common
response to this this keeps the a file
closed
yes the pawn on b3 is a monster and you
can try to play rook c8 and
send the rook over to c2 but bishop d3
stops it
white can play black is a big initiative
black is not winning here
so i would advocate for this approach
uh alex if i were you knight takes b3
allows this tactic
and this attack is absolutely
devastating of course after we take the
rook the game is over
that was a lot for one game but i never
before played the night or
and uh it's it's not an easy opening to
sort of
introduce in elevator pitch style so i
hope
this made at least a little bit of sense